it took the u.n security council less
than 10 minutes to decide who should
lead the world's most powerful
international organization
for the next five years its choice for
the next secretary general
that mr antonio couter
is the current secretary general antonio
guterres's first appointment in 2016 was
announced with a rare public showing of
unity from council members
this time may have lacked the fanfare
but the council president had high
praise for the incumbent
we have all seen actually the secretary
general in action i think he has been an
excellent secretary general
he's a bridge builder nevertheless
guterres style of quiet diplomacy has
been a disappointment for human rights
organizations
who say he's been too reluctant to
criticize the powerful governments who
handed him the job
so when it came to myanmar and the
military coup that we saw a few months
ago he was very vocal on that and he
moved the un system
into doing something he made the
security council meet
on the situation straight away but then
on other situations
saudi arabia egypt china where we're now
seeing a million people in these
internment count
camps most of them being tortured as we
speak
there is silence his spokesperson
defended his record
we all have the same goal and that is
seeing
uh an end to human rights abuses
we all take different roads to get there
but in the end we all want to get to the
same place two-term secretaries general
are not unusual nor are backroom deals
to nominate candidates
but the process that led to antonio
guterres's first five-year term
was hailed as the most open in u.n
history
reforms that again allowed member states
to nominate and interview candidates
publicly
but this time yielded no other
officially recognized competitors
the general assembly still has to
approve the decision before the
secretary general's place in history is
official
a move that is widely expected kristin
salumi al jazeera
the united nations